CodeTalk (Rethinking IDE Accessibility)
Modern IDEs like Visual Studio have taken
great strides to make their tools usable by visually impaired people.
But, they're far from making it an enjoyable experience.
Due to the linear nature of information flow between the IDE, screen
reader and the user, a lot of features
are not accessible to the screen users that the sighted users take for granted.
These features can be grouped into three categories:
Glanceability:
The ability of a sighted developer to quickly glance through tremendous
amounts of code, structure, and debugging information.
This is completely unavailable to a visually impaired user due to screen reader limitations
Debugging information such as break points are also not accessible to visually impaired users.
Navigability:
The ability to quickly navigate through code. Since visually impaired users cannot glance at
code structure, skipping and moving between functions comments and blocks
of code, becomes very cumbersome.
Alertability:
Visual Studio gives the developer real-time added information through visual cues.
This is completely inaccessible to a screen reader user.
CodeTalk is a Visual Studio plugin that aims to address these issues.
With CodeTalk, visually impaired developers can quickly navigate through code, get access to real-time
error information, and debug with a completely new debugging experience
we call TalkPoints.
For more details visit aka.ms/CodeTalk.